joe rogan continues this sort of like uh
turning on donald trump rogan now um
acknowledged that he believes donald
trump was regularly on
uppers during his presidency and called
them a man baby during a a a recent show
this is interesting for a couple reasons
which i will tell you
um daily beast reporting joe rogan calls
trump a drugged out man baby the mega
popular podcaster laughed at trump's
inability to focus on anything but
himself in his latest episode trump uh
and rogan now and i guess what we would
call a feud
um
and uh rogan suggesting that trump's
energy comes from adderall called him a
man baby this was during a conversation
with comedian and frequent guest tom
segura let's take a look at this and
i'll tell you why it's interesting in a
moment well about that guy is that you
know i'm saying even when you when you
watch him as president he was full of
energy full of it every day and they
said he slept like four hours a night
he's one of those people son adderall
god do you think he's on adderall
yes
i do only because
there were multiple people who used to
work on the apprentice that were like he
was
gassed up for shoots really yeah because
he has trouble reading he doesn't he he
would he would struggle to read prompter
or script when he was just
let's say sober
so they would give him that and he would
dial in more on reading because he gets
he gets very bored they said you know
yeah he would get bored at the cia
briefing in the mornings he was like i
don't want to read that there's a daily
briefing you get as president he's like
you read it and then tell me and if it's
boring so they would have to make it
more engaging for him because he would
have heard they would put his name in
briefings
multiple times to keep him interested
and then
kushner you know his son-in-law
said that he came up with a formula
uh to keep him engaged this is called
the bad news sandwich it's often done in
a lot of venues
yes because you know he obviously was
close to him and knew him well and the
formula was
um
like
two good one bad so if they were gonna
give them bad news they keep going you
start with some good news
so they go this is going well
everybody's thrilled with you about this
here's a bad thing
also people love you for this
so that's how that's how they would tell
them bad news they couldn't just go tip
is a bunch of bad of course yeah he's a
man baby he's a toddler
he's a toddler so there's two things
here and i think that they're both
important to mention number one
whatever you think about joe rogan and i
have been very hard on rogan we've done
at this point what 20 different
critiques of things rogan has done and
when rogan does something good we will
praise it as well there's no ideological
or emotional attachment to it or
whatever the case may be
rogan's got a lot of trump supporters in
his audience and some of them are the
kind of
they play that they're enlightened
centrists sometimes they even claim to
read books they often don't but they
claim to
and
a lot of them support trump but they
don't openly and brazenly do it but they
do at the end of the day they go well
yeah i mean i voted for trump because i
decided at the end of the day this that
the other thing it is important
and it is impactful
particularly when the reports are
trump's going to announce his 2024 uh
president candidacy for president for
the primary anyway very soon
it is important that
the culturally conservative audience of
rogan
not everybody i know there's liberals
who listen to rogan i watch some
episodes sometimes
um the culturally conservative people in
rogan's audience start to see
that alpha male rogan
is laughing at trump man baby not a
particularly alpha thing to call a guy
right it's quite beta in fact by their
nomenclature and standards that's a good
thing and it's a good thing for people
in rogan's audience to see that
the problem is rogan supports ron
desantis for 2024 at least he said
he likes desantis he would vote for him
likes him i forget the exact wording but
it was
almost an endorsement uh but saying he
would be a great president
so
one element is simply assuming that this
isn't all
deliberate in order to prop up desantis
as a calculated thing maybe it is maybe
it isn't but even if it's not
that the criticism is all contextualized
by
rogan likes desantis who's like an even
more dangerous donald trump so
is this a good thing in the net or not
is this sort of like a de facto offense
for desantis i don't know
trading trump for desantis as president
if you said to me
either trump or desantis will be
president who do you want it to be
i think trump's less dangerous
because although he's dumber he gets
less done he's so unorganized and he's
so caught up in nonsense that i think he
gets less done
um
so
it's
if rogan can disabuse trumpists of
following trump and supporting trump
great and if he can do it in a way that
feels like that beta trump no i'm alpha
i'm with rogan whatever whatever it
takes right to to disabuse them of those
beliefs
but if it leads to desantis being the
next president or the nominee then we've
got some real problems and i don't know
the answer i don't know where it's going
as many of you know i'm a busy person i
don't always have the exact correct
nutritional plan for my meals every
single day and that's why i also take a
multivitamin and a couple of supplements
but doing them all separately can be a
little bit time consuming which is why
athletic greens is just fantastic and
they're one of our sponsors i've been
using the athletic greens since last
year it just really simplifies nutrition
i just do a scoop of the ag-1 and i'm
getting 75 high quality vitamins and
minerals and my probiotics and it's all
from whole food sources i drink it in
the morning i know i'm good i don't have
to be messing around with different
pills and supplements or whatever or
spend time planning when what time of
day do i need to take each one i just
get it all with one scoop you can put it
in a smoothie you can drink it straight
it tastes great and then i'm just good
for the day
it supports gut health and i'm getting
everything that i need and i'm looking
for athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d plus five free travel packs
when you go to athleticgreens.com
pacman and the link is down below